mahmoud hussein will soon be enjoying
more family moments
this was one of the rare occasions he
saw his loved ones
during more than four years in prison
the al jazeera journalist was detained
in december 2016
after arriving in cairo on a trip home
from his base in doha
the egyptian was never formally charged
but was accused of incitement
broadcasting false news and receiving
foreign funds
to defame state institutions he
and al jazeera consistently denied the
allegations
during his time inside cairo's notorious
torah maximum security prison
he was denied his rights he suffered a
broken arm
and was refused proper medical treatment
the detention
also breached egypt's penal code he was
locked up for two and a half years more
than the maximum time allowed to hold
someone without charge
my father is emotionally and mentally
distressed because he feels that he is
there on the dark cell behind the bars
without committing any crime
and he's away from his children his
family his father his mother
and he can't do anything rights groups
have reported an unparalleled crackdown
on journalists
in egypt under former general now
president
abdul fattah al-sisi in 2013
al-jazeera journalist bahir muhammad
muhammad farmi and peter grester
were imprisoned on charges of spreading
false news
they were released after a year
ibrahimow the former editor-in-chief of
al-jazeera arabic
was sentenced to death in abstentia for
endangering national security
reporters without borders ranks egypt at
166 out of 180 countries
in its index of press freedom while
hussein is now free
says at least 30 journalists remain in
egyptian prisons
charlotte ballas al jazeera